On September 13, 1848, Gage was helping excavate
rocks to make way for a railroad track on
the Rutland and Burlington Railroad near Cavendish
in Vermont.
Just prior to the accident, Gage was preparing
for an explosion by compacting a bore with
explosive powder using a tamping iron.
A spark created from the tamping iron ignited
the powder, driving the iron straight through
Gage’s skull.
It entered under the left cheek bone and exited
completely through the top of the head, and
was later recovered some 30 yards away, smeared
with blood and brain matter.
To have an idea of extent of damage this iron
would have caused, you need to realize its
size.
The tamping iron was 3 ft 8 in.
(1.11 m) in length and 1.25 inches (3.18 cm)
in diameter at one end and tapered over a
distance of about 1 ft., to 0.25 inches (0.6
cm) in diameter, weighing approximately 13
pounds (6 kg).
After the rod passed through his head, it
is not known whether or not Gage ever lost
consciousness, but within minutes of his injury,
at the astonishment of the men on his crew,
he was walking and talking and he sat upright
in an oxcart for the 3/4 mile ride to his
house where he was attended to by Dr. Edward
H. Williams, who describes the situation when
he first saw Gage:
When I drove up he said, ‘Doctor, here is
business enough for you.’
I first noticed the wound upon the head before
I alighted from my carriage, the pulsations
of the brain being very distinct.
The top of the head appeared somewhat like
an inverted funnel … as if some wedge-shaped
body had passed from below upward.
Mr. Gage, during the time I was examining
this wound, was relating the manner in which
he was injured to the bystanders.
I did not believe Mr. Gage’s statement at
that time, but thought he was deceived.
Mr. Gage persisted in saying that the bar
went through his head …. Mr. G. got up and
vomited; the effort of vomiting pressed out
about half a teacupful of the brain, which
fell upon the floor.
By evening, Dr. John Martyn Harlow had taken
over the case and it was his notes of observations
about Phineas’ injury, subsequent recovery
and personality changes that provided evidence
that the frontal cortex is involved in one’s
personality.
The initial treatment of Phineas’ physical
injuries included cleaning the wound by removing
small fragments of bone and replacing some
of the larger fragments that were still attached
but displaced.
The large wound at the top of his head was
closed with adhesive straps and covered with
a wet compress, to allow the wound to drain
into the dressings.
Within days, his exposed brain became infected
and he fell into a semi-comatose state.
To his family’s relief and surprise, he
recovered.
Not long after that, Dr. Harlow had to release
8 fluid ounces of pus from an abscess under
George’s scalp.
Despite all this, only three and a half months
after the accident, Phineas Gage was leading
a seemingly normal life, contrary to many
outlandish accounts that soon popped up, most
of which have been dismissed as myth, due
to complete lack of evidence.
However, those closest to him did notice slight
changes in his personality and behavior.
In 1868, in a report published in the Bulletin
of the Massachusetts Medical Society , Dr.
Harlow wrote,
His contractors, who regarded him as the most
efficient and capable foreman in their employ
previous to his injury, considered the change
in his mind so marked that they could not
give him his place again.
He is fitful, irreverent, indulging at times
in the grossest profanity (which was not previously
his custom), manifesting but little deference
for his fellows, impatient of restraint of
advice when it conflicts with his desires,
at times pertinaciously obstinent, yet capricious
and vacillating, devising many plans of future
operation, which are no sooner arranged than
they are abandoned in turn for others appearing
more feasible.
In this regard, his mind was radically changed,
so decidedly that his friends and acquaintances
said he was ‘no longer Gage’.
Not the same man he used to be and denied
employment by the railroad company who used
to see him as an efficient and capable foreman,
he worked for a short time at a livery stable
in New Hampshire, among other odd jobs.
He then spent seven years as a stagecoach
driver in Chile until his health began to
deteriorate.
Evidence uncovered very recently, in 2008,
seems to indicate that before his demise while
working in Chile, Gage had recovered most,
if not all, of his former social skills and
was otherwise a pretty normal guy at this
point.
Once his health declined, he moved to San
Francisco with his mother where, after suffering
a series of epileptic seizures he died on
May 20, 1860 at the age of 36 – almost 12
years after his accident.
It wasn’t until 1866 that Dr. Harlow, who
had thought he would never hear from Phineas
again, learned of his death.
At his request to the family, Phineas’ skull
was removed from his grave and sent, along
with the tamping iron that had pierced Phineas’
skull, to Dr. Harlow in Massachusetts.
Today, both can be seen at the Harvard University
School of Medicine in the Warren Anatomical
Museum.